what's going on guys welcome to another
uh python mathematics and charting stock
indicators tutorial video
uh the last videos that we just made
were the arun uh
indicators right so this is where we
left off
and that arun indicator gave us
something like this when we ran it
right so we had this and actually let me
change this let's go
let me change this back to 10 years not
just one year
10-year data run it one more time apple
and here's our indicator so so this is
what the rune indicator had been giving
us
now um the next thing is the arun
oscillator and luckily the difference
between the arun indicator
and the rune arun oscillator is so minut
that i'm just going to do it
all in the same video so the idea of the
rune oscillator is the same as the
indicator
the only difference is to is to kind of
combine these two things
into one thing and then you just usually
fill between you could just make it a
single line
but generally people fill between
because the uh
it's not necessarily a directional
indicator it's
more of like an intensity indicator so
you wouldn't want it to just be a single
line you kind of want to use a fill
between just to kind of bring that point
home but anyway
so that's what we're going to be doing
in this video the calculation for it is
simply
the high minus the low that's it and
then the rest of it is just kind of um
some matplot lib coating to get it to
fill in between
short enough for me to do it in this
video now a couple quick
uh images of what we'll be doing that
was just the regular like this is the
image of what we just made
right this is your arun uh normal
typical runoff
uh indicator and this would be a typical
arun
oscillator right so you've got the high
minus the low obviously
as it's going up you're going to see it
you know
it goes up like this and sure enough
it's that way until it reaches this
point kind of low then back
up again and then again at about this
point just after it starts saying hey
watch out and sure enough there it goes
all the way down
now the next thing i would like to do is
change
this and use fill between to make up
green down red just to make it even more
clear
so that'll look more like this and so
we'll be doing that
now within matplotlib so uh
let me just we'll stop this from running
uh and we'll come over here and go
down to uh where we actually coded this
which will be here
now what we all we need to do is create
a couple of new things
we're going to need to make a new array
for one so we're going to want
an arun oscillator
array that'll be an empty array for now
and then we need to
start populating it so within this wow
loop
we'll want to uh call the arun
oscillator so we're just going to give
it a simple variable here roon
underscore osc
and that's going to equal um a rune
underscore up minus a
rune underscore
down so that's really all the
calculation required for the urine
oscillator which is why i'm just going
to go ahead and condense it into one
video
after we have defined it we're going to
append it to this one so i'm just going
to copy that
hit paste dot append and append
arun underscore ask
that's it now uh when we go to return
we want to just add that to the end so
we'll also return
and i'll just paste again since it's
still there arun oscillator
now when we come down here and we say
what
this function is going to spit out we
need to add one more variable and that's
going to be ao
for a roon oscillator now i'm going to
go ahead and
silence these two bad boys because we
don't need them anymore and now we need
to do
a fill between function so the simple
fill between
um where that's not colored would be
ax2.fill
underscore between and between what
a date minus sp colon
uh that's your y or your x rather your y
variable is going to be a
o minus sp colon
then we want to fill between what well
the zero line is
is the kind of the fill between line
there
and then uh we're going to make the face
color equal
to just a non-discrete white and we're
going to give it an alpha
equals 0.0 or 0.5
and that just kind of alpha is the
measure of how opaque something is
so the more opaque the more transparent
or the less opaque
the more transparent there we go save
that
uh looks good let's go ahead and run it
see if
we did everything right bring it over
we'll plot apple
sure enough we did everything right
we've got apple here that oscillator
is all fine and dandy now let's go ahead
and talk about how we could color it if
we wanted to
uh we'll do this close out of that
so to change this we really
let's say we want to do the upward one
first i'm just going to delete
all the way back to this zero mark
now you add a function here call
with where equals something
and what we want to do is where ao
is minus sp colon
is greater than uh greater than equal to
uh zero
we would like that face color to be
green
and uh then we want the alpha again
equals 0.5
close off your parentheses there now
we can't run this just yet because this
where clause is going to require
a numpy array it can't just be a python
list
so what we've got to do now is turn this
ao into a numpy array luckily it's
really simple it's just mp dot array
and just in case all the way to the
minus sp part
in that and you're all set now what i
want to go ahead and do
is we're just going to highlight this
entire line
copy back over
paste change this to red change this
to less than or equal to zero
and that's it now let's go ahead and
save that run that
plot up again we'll just do apple
and here is our new uh a rune oscillator
uh that's color coded now so it just
looks just slightly better
in my honest opinion and it's a lot more
um
clear to anybody who's looking at it
what this actually means
so anyway that's the uh conclusion to my
uh short tutorial on the
arun oscillator short enough so we can
just jam it all into one video
pretty cool uh thing you can do here
with it it makes just the chart
that much better and a lot more clear to
actually read for somebody so
anyway hopefully uh you guys have
enjoyed as always thanks for watching
thanks for the support and subscriptions
and until
next time